الكرسي الأخير يستفيد الأطفال الصغار من
اليقظة من خلال التعرف على
أنفسهم وأولياء أمورهم
ومحيطهم بشكل أفضل وعندما يفعلون ذلك
فإنهم يميلون إلى أن يكونوا أكثر راحة
ويمكنهم أيضًا تعلم كيفية فهم
عواطفهم بشكل أفضل والاستقرار
اليوم سنقوم  العب بعض
الألعاب اليقظة التي يمكن تكييفها للأطفال
من جميع الأعمار ولكن اليوم
سأقدمها بطريقة مناسبة
لسن المدرسة الابتدائية ،
دعونا نغير كرة
الثلج ، كرة الثلج هي طريقة رائعة لتوضيح
للأطفال كيف عندما  العقول مشغولة
عندما تشعر بالكثير من التوتر ، من الصعب
رؤية العالم بوضوح ، دعنا فقط
نراقب قليلاً
ما يحدث
إنه يشبه عاصفة ثلجية
تنتهي وتتحول إلى ثلج
ولكن ما يحدث عندما نشعر جميعًا
بالضيق إذا شعرنا بالضيق  إنه
يشبه هذا إلى حد ما حيث يتساقط الثلج
بسرعة كبيرة وقوية
لدرجة أننا لا نشعر بالهدوء أو الاستقرار
، نجلس ونشعر
بتنفسنا ونشاهد الثلج واليقظة
تنشط  ity هو مجرد
الجلوس وترك كل شيء يهدأ ،
دعنا نبقى ثابتًا ونرى
ما
سيحدث ،
إنه
أسهل ، لذا فإن اليقظة الذهنية لن
تتخلص من كل ضغوطك ولكنها
تعطينا أداة لمساعدتنا على الاستقرار ومعرفة
ما يحدث في  ومن حولنا
بوضوح واتخذ خيارات صحية
حسنًا ، يد واحدة على
بطنك تشعر أن
تنفسك ، يساعدك التخلص من التمرين على
الاستقرار عندما تشعر بالضيق عندما
يكون من الصعب حقًا الجلوس وأنت
عالق قدميك على
الأرض  سنستمر في هز ركبتيك
حتى تسمع ركبتيك وعندما
تسمع الطبلة ،
ستهتز  قم بالتبديل بين
فترات الحركة والسكون التي
لديها طريقة
لتهدئة نظامك العصبي وتهدئة جسدك ،
وسوف نتظاهر
بأنك تهز فايجو نائمًا ،
تنزل على بطنك ،
فإن تمرين الروكابي يساعد الأطفال على التعثر
النوم يساعدهم على تهدئة أذهانهم من
خلال جعلهم ينقلون انتباههم إلى
الشعور بهز حيوان محشو
للنوم على بطنهم ، هل يمكنك تحريك faygo
لأعلى ولأسفل
مع تنفسك في faygo يرتفع
ويخرج زفير faygo ينزل
للسماح للطفل  تنفس بشكل طبيعي إذا
كان الطفل صغيرًا جدًا ويواجه
صعوبة في التركيز على الشعور
بحركة أنفاسه ، فقط اطلب
منهم مشاهدة الحيوان المحشو وهو يرتفع لأعلى ولأسفل ،
أشعر بالحيوان المحشو على ما
يبدو وكأنه يحاول القفز إلى
السقف
إذا  أنت جالس هناك معتقدًا أن
طفلي لن يمارس هذا أبدًا ، دعني
أخبرك أنه يمكن أن يحدث أن يكون الأطفال
منتبهين بشكل طبيعي وأحيانًا
نشعر أننا نعلمهم ألا يكونوا منتبهين لذلك
إذا كان بإمكاننا
الاستقرار والتواجد مع
طفلنا  ولكي نكون معهم هناك
الكثير الذي يمكننا تعلمه منهم
[موسيقى]